Hey Stephen it is the 1970s and you are
killing it right now thank the cocaine
Carrie is flying off the shelf we're
gonna keep this money train going we're
gonna need about 50 or 60 more books and
it is in your contract uh
I'm starting the timer and go uh what if
vampires were scary I'm gonna start
writing these down what if hotels were
scary oh yeah what if a virus was scary
that might be relative what if walking
was scary what if politicians were scary
what if fire what if roads were scary I
think we gotta do that under a different
name though what if dogs were scary all
right we're back on track what if
running was scared
um what is Cowboys were scary what if
cars were scary what if dying was scary
what if werewolves were scary what if
losing weight was scared what if fear
was scary um yeah that uh that might be
a Steven that might be enough what if
fantasy was scary what if doors were
scary what if writing was scary what if
aliens were scared the aliens sell I bet
that'll be your best book what if pen
names were scary okay what if trains
were scary what if capitalism was scary
what if marriage was scary what if sleep
was scary what if paintings were scary
what if prisons were scary what if
Nevada was scary what if Ohio was scary
what if orbs were scary what if a bag of
bones was scary I I don't know what that
book is about what if baseball was scary
what if aliens were scared didn't we do
that one before yeah but these ones come
from your ass what what if a different
type of car was scary what if the
snitches from Harry Potter were scary
Stephen it's 1975. I've met too many
Harry Potters you have to clarify which
what if I was scary uh why what if I was
even scarier okay
past what if cell phones were scary what
if I died
and it was scary what if I was Mice and
Men was scary what if Florida was scary
what if the Simpsons movie was scary
what if time travel was scary what if
that friend who never shuts up was scary
no I can't imagine that one what if
amusement parks were scary what if
sequels were scary what if serial
killers were scary what if religion was
scary what if crime was scary what if
trilogies were scary what if
doppelgangers were scared what if losing
weight was scary again what if stranger
things was scary what if being a Hitman
was scary what if fairy tales were scary
that was impressive great we got that
down have fun not deviating from that
list for the rest of your career all
right what